these waves you know you know turning
upside down and everything so it makes
you just stumble which puzzle stumped
you the most and did you know that 1899
is actually a first for Netflix let's
talk all those juicy behind the scenes
details that helped make this first
season so fun number one you've never
seen anything like this before 1899 is
the first series from Netflix to be
filmed using LED volume technology it
may look like the actors are traveling
over stormy seas and through giant
glaciers but in reality they're standing
in front of a massive screen
encompassing the entire set LED volume
technology uses a video game engine to
create virtual sets allowing our cast to
become fully immersed in their
environment you see the whole landscape
in front of you so you're really looking
at the seat number two we hope you don't
get seasick the ship was placed on a
gimbal rig and a rotating plate meaning
that it was actually in motion either
turning on the plate or rocking with the
the waves not only that but apparently
the LED volume technology looked so
realistic that several members of the
cast got seasick Andreas peachman was
unlucky enough to be one of them I felt
quite dizzy on Deck you know we're
looking at those ways all the time well
an iron Barnard revealed that some
people needed to rely on medication to
get by number three 1899 is a
multi-language show the series cast out
of Germany Norway Iceland France Hong
Kong Spain Poland Portugal and Denmark
with each one of the actors speaking in
their native language Rosalie Craig said
that she found she didn't really think
about the fact she couldn't understand
her co-stars at times it's just there
it's just it's just in the scene and you
just have to get on with it Rosalie
found there to be an element of real
life to the series because of it number
four did you know the idea for 1899 came
from a creepy old photo the showrunner
stumbled upon it while researching
another project and described it as a
picture of a man in a white shirt
covered in blood with a ham hammer in
his hand and a really weird look on his
face standing on top of what looked like
an old boat they were apparently drawn
to the photo and began asking questions
like where does he come from leading
them to write 1899 like a little bit of
an experiment number five this is one
way to get an authentic score series
composer Ben Frost recorded the score
for 1899 from inside a real fishing
vessel in Iceland he would then take
these recordings and feed them through a
Bluetooth speaker to use the hull of the
ship almost like a Reverb chamber Frost
explained they were only allowed into
these fishing vessels because they were
under repair at the time so while I'm in
there with a recording of violins
there's also some guy drilling the wall
or using an arc welder in the next cabin
number six can you guess why the series
is set in 1899 well according to yantia
Frieza what we really liked about 1899
not 1898 or 1897 is that it's on a
threshold you're Crossing into a new
century stepping from something that
feels old school to something new the
future beyond that Baron also pointed
out that 1899 is very magical as he
explained it one plus eight is nine so
you have 9.99 if you turn that upside
down it's 666 the Number of the Beast
number seven imagine this on your last
day on the job Baron revealed in an
interview with tudum that on the last
day of filming all of the actors had
been put into pods and weren't able to
move going on to joke finally we could
do whatever we wanted with them odar
said that he played weird music for the
cast while Barnard recalled odar's
Antics saying and um he started playing
the Welsh national anthem Barnard added
that it made him laugh a lot number
eight did you notice all the triangles
in 1899 they are everywhere in the
show's wardrobe hidden in the background
on set and perhaps most importantly in
the pyramid-shaped tetrahedron Baron Bo
odar and yancha Frieza explained in an
interview with tudum that they chose
this shape because the tetrahedron is
the purest geometrical form you use to
create all the other forms before adding
that the reoccurring triangle symbol
itself represents the element Earth
making this one multi-layered symbol
number nine did you catch all the Easter
eggs Baron bow odar and yantya Frieza
have been sure to include plenty of
little details that are meant to in
their words subconsciously or
consciously trigger something in your
head like that room number 1011 is
actually a reference to binary code the
steamship cameras is in honor of a
computer Authentication Protocol while
the name Prometheus is meant to serve as
a little wink to the ending of season
one number ten a lot more went into
playing more than you'd expect Emily
Beacham revealed that she had to keep a
mental map of where her character was
supposed to be emotionally for every
scene explaining that the chaotic nature
of her character as well as the fact
that they weren't filming in sequential
order could sometimes get confusing not
only that but Beacham would also reveal
that a lot of the decisions were made on
the set and so she needed to meet with
barenbeau odar every morning to help
plot out her character number 11 what
happens when you mix water and
Technology you probably know nothing
good but even though 1899 would be
filming around some pretty new equipment
in fact LED volume technology is so new
that we aren't even fully aware of its
limits yet it was important to the
showrunners that the rain be included in
some way and so the sfx team came up
with a new way to control the rain
rigging and water piping so that it
wouldn't damage any of the equipment all
the while getting our actors properly
drenched number 12 did you notice any
visual effects Baron bow odar admitted
that for 1899 he took inspiration from
films like alien and The Shining
especially trying to replicate that
creepy feeling of corridors and how much
you can see or not see but one movie he
doesn't want you to compare 1899 to is
Titanic he explained that although he
loved Titanic when it came out he was
worried that the image of a big
steamship going from Europe to America
would already be enough to bring the
movie to audiences Minds which he tried
to avoid as much as possible number 13
what did you think the opening credit
song was referencing some online
suggested that the series's use of White
Rabbit could be a throwback to The
Matrix but that's not quite so yantia
told The Hollywood Reporter that the
song was more of a reference to the
brain to psychology and the science of
perception she pointed out that the most
prominent line is feed your head adding
that was such an important phrase for
the entire show that it felt like the
absolute right fit number 14 imagine
going on strange Adventures without ever
leaving your country that's what Baron
and yantya got to do the use of LED
volume technology meant that the
majority of filming needed to be done
out of a single location studio
battlesperg in Potsdam Germany for us it
was essential to stay here in Germany
but for any scenes where you see the
characters before boarding the ship all
of that was filmed in London England
number 15. we all have bad ideas now and
again when discussing the writing
process of 1899 Baron Beau odar revealed
that it was a highly collaborative
process between him and yankya it's
really a lot of bouncing back and forth
between the two of us throwing in random
ideas in the beginning and trying to
figure out what ideas actually stick
when asked if they'd ever suggested any
bad ideas odar said one bad idea we've
definitely said is not going to happen
is that 1899 is related to dark meaning
that we won't be seeing any crossover
number 16 are you afraid of tight spaces
and iron Barnard is he said that the set
for 1899 was so uncomfortable he
compared it to a prison like any ship
you know it's almost like a prison he
went on to complain that the ceilings
onset had been built very low the rooms
were small and the corridors had a
confusing maze-like quality that could
become mentally draining Emily Beacham
agreed saying that the shoot required a
lot of energy especially doing it over
six months is like a big old Marathon we
can't even imagine having to endure this
filming process which behind the scenes
detail did you find to be the most
shocking make sure to let us know down
in the comments